le 15 février 2015 je postais le premier
épisode de chroniques de profs sur ma
chaîne ce qui fait qu'elle a aujourd'hui
trois ans
[Musique]
et avant de faire le bilan de ces trois
années de joie et d'histoire je voulais
vous parler de l'histoire des
anniversaires justement durant une
grande partie du moyen-âge les
anniversaires sont peu célébré pour des
raisons religieuses déjà avec la
christianisation de l'europe occidentale
les anniversaires ont tendance à
disparaître parce que considérés comme
païens dans la bible les jours des
anniversaires sont souvent associés à
des jours de malheur et enfin on
considère que le jour de sa naissance on
n'a encore rien réalisé alors ça serait
un peu prétentieux et individualiste de
le fêter
les autres raisons pour lesquelles on
fait peu son anniversaire sont d'ordre
matériel
il faudrait déjà savoir quel jour on est
né ce qui n'est pas toujours évident
qu'en l'absence de registres d'état
civil mais aussi savoir quel jour on est
pendant tout le reste de sa vie
et quelle année et ça n'est pas donné à
tout le monde puisque ça suppose d'avoir
un calendrier et même on se souvenant de
sa date de naissance et en ayant un
calendrier sous les yeux bah il faut
aussi savoir compter suffisamment pour
savoir qu'est la journée et ça non plus
ça n'est pas donné à tout le monde
du coup durant tous moyen-âge
l'anniversaire yomou renvoie plutôt aux
jours de la mort d'une personne ça on
peut le fêter puisque sa marque l'entrée
de la personne dans l'au delà qui est un
petit peu plus prestigieux connaître
quand même c'est pourquoi on commémore
beaucoup les défunts et ça explique
aussi que la plupart des jours saints
ont fait célèbre la date à laquelle le
sein en question est mort et non pas sa
date de naissance
les seules exceptions sont pour jésus à
la vierge marie et saint jean baptiste
dont on fête à date de naissance pour
les autres celles en bas on fait quand
même la fête au moyen-âge parce qu'on
apprécie tout de même un petit peu la
joie de vivre mais on marque d'autres
occasions par exemple on fait beaucoup
ça fait le jour du sein qui porte notre
nom quoi
de même il est courant de vouer un culte
particulier au sein du jour de sa
naissance
c'est le cas de charles 5 par exemple
qui est né le jour de la sainte agnès et
qui a donc tendance à lui rendre un
hommage particulier ce jour là on fait
aussi le jour de son baptême quand on a
les moyens de s'en souvenir parce qu'il
marque sa vraie entrée dans la vie et
puis on observe quand même importance du
jour de naissance en astrologique
puisque les personnes les plus
puissantes du roi les princes se font
faire des horoscopes de naissance qui
indiquent la position des planètes dans
le ciel le jour de leur naissance
pour ça il faut connaître ce jour de
naissance les astrologues réalise aussi
des révolutions naissance qui sont des
horoscopes réalisé le jour de l'année où
le soleil est revenu à la même place
qu'il occupait à la naissance de la
personne donc à peu de choses près ça
correspond au jour de l'anniversaire
r par exemple voici une révolution de
naissance pour le duc de bretagne en
l'an 2000 426 j'avais la même à
disposition pour les ducs de bourgogne
mais comme nous en parle tout le temps
je me suis dit allez marion va partir du
xvième siècle avec la réforme on
commence à fêter un petit peu plus et
anniversaire met donc au moyen âge ça
reste une fête très peu voire même pas
du tout célébré et ont préféré souhaiter
d'autre chose en rapport avec la vie et
donc pour revenir à l'anniversaire de
cette chaîne et ben c'est l'occasion de
faire aussi un petit bilan
comme je l'avais dit dans la faq je
crois que j'ai eu l'idée de créer cette
chaîne il ya trois ans enfin la chaîne a
été créé en décembre la première vidéo
est sortie le 15 février
le temps de la faire quoi et je me
souviens que avant de lancer la chaîne
je mettais envoyé un mail vers le futur
parce qu'il existe des sites comme ça où
l'on peut envoyer des mails vers le
futur et je vais envoyer à dans cinq ans
à l'époque donc j'imagine que je le
recevrai dans deux ans on n'achète plus
exactement quand et qui me dit j'espère
que tu as mis en pratique cette idée que
tu as eue et dont je parlais de la
chaîne et c'est cool parce que quand je
recevrai le mail bon je pourrais dire
oui je vais fait c'est un peu bizarre
que sinon c'est parti pour un petit
bilan de la chaîne en images
donc là on est sur la première vidéo où
il y avait énormément de jaune c'est
assez moche et aussi beaucoup de
raccourcis
j'avais au début je voulais juste faire
une vidéo sur la bataille de lécluse
mais je me suis dit bon on va faire la
guerre de cent ans
en dix minutes même pas donc jarre
ferait peut-être un jour une brève vidéo
très complète sur la guerre de cent ans
avec un peu plus de recherche sont
pourrait bien de faire ça et j'avais un
truc avec les baignoires dans les
premières vidéos on les voit soulom ma
mémoire qu'elle était pas mal
la dent deuxième épisode c'est là qu'on
voit apparaître aliénor et pas mal de
personnages en costumes fait maintenant
j'utilise surtout adenauer et le critias
mais un peu moins d'autres costumes
peut-être que ça reviendra et moi chaque
fois ça implique de changer encore la
baignoire un donc et aussi dans ses
premiers épisodes le problème c'est que
donc là je finis dans ma chambre de chez
mon père l'a fait naître était un peu
mal orientées ce qui fait que souvent
j'avais la tête de scarface et un côté
noir un côté blanc et mon ce troisième
épisode sur la révolution en plus il
était beaucoup trop court pour parler de
la révolution française c'était un petit
peu ambitieux de ma part mais bon on
fait un petit saut dans le temps entre
temps j'ai présenté pas mal de choses
notamment des peuples les vikings des
pictes et ça ça m'a bien plu même si
techniquement il y aura des choses à
redire mais je pense qu'au contenu et
est pas trop mal encore l'épisode i
c'était un peu spécial puisqu'il s'agit
de devenir prof
donc c'est le seul épisode qui ne
parlent pas d'histoire mais de métier de
prof d'histoire d'art il a pas mal
marché apparemment puisqu'il ya pas mal
de personnes qui m'ont posé des
questions par rapport à ça donc j'espère
qu'il a aidé des personnes à s'orienter
en devenir prof en tout cas c'était le
but
juste après cet épisode c'est aussi
moment où j'ai lancé les ultimes prof
au départ ça s'appelait pas comme ça
donc le premier était sur l'eau la
couleur rose une histoire des
sensibilités et au départ c'était un
projet avec d'autres vidéaste femmes sur
youtube on avait décidé de lancer les
créatrices du tube on se proposait
chacune un sujet et ont traité une vidéo
en rapport avec ce sujet donc le premier
thème c'était le rose le deuxième était
halloween c'est pour ça que j'ai parlé
du sabbat et après on a laissé tomber
c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé de
renommer en bulletins profs pour
continuer à faire des épisodes un peu
plus court sans les autres personnages
et avec plus d'illustrations et même
avec les premières images en extérieur à
une vidéo sur le valhalla
même si ce n'était pas du tout prévu
puisque c'était une vidéo de vacances
et après ça du coup on a un changement
de décor puisque j'ai déménagé j'ai pris
mon premier appart
il y avait une meilleure lumière ça
c'était bien et j'ai pu faire la suite
de mon histoire de la piraterie que
j'avais commencé qu'à pas eu énormément
de vue c'est dommage parce que j'aime
bien mais c'est la première fois aussi
que je chantais au générique et ses
habitudes que j'ai gardées depuis même
si je suis pas du tout une chanteuse jeu
forte mais j'aime bien à partir
d'épisodes douce je trouve qu'il ya eu
un tournant dans la chaîne parce que
j'ai fait beaucoup plus de recherches
pour mes sujets et donc même s'il ya
toujours de l'humour je prouve que ce
sont des vidéos plus travaillé et plus
sérieuse enfin j'espère je m'efforce de
faire ça que dans les premiers épisodes
je consultais voit peut-être un livre et
puis je faisais surtout beaucoup
d'internet non pas du wikipédia mais
c'était pas très recherché et depuis
l'épisode 12 c'est l'inversé vraiment
très peu d'internet dans lequel je vais
chercher parfois des infos
complémentaires mais sinon je vais à la
dé lui je consulte des livres et jeux
les fiches ça prend du temps
c'est pour ça que les épisodes sont plus
longs mais aussi mettre un peu de temps
à sortir mais c'est comme ça que ça me
plaît le 15 c'est un des épisodes
préférés
déjà il ya lucrecia qui apparaît donc
s'il n'avait pas dit à l'époque mais la
romaine et surtout sa part du mur
d'hadrien j'avais des belles images et
j'ai beaucoup aimé le faire le 18 c'est
l'épisode où j'ai le plus de vues
forcément vu le sujet puisqu'on parle
d'albert ronde et je pense qu'il a été
partagé quelque part parce que il est à
65 minutes 20 ans ce qui est énorme par
rapport aux autres vidéos mais en tout
cas il était drôle j'aime bien et
pendant l'été donné 17 c'est aussi là
que j'ai créé le projet gentes dames
bada ce qui fait de l'histoire des
femmes et donc il présente la biographie
de femmes importantes dont j'avais filmé
coup sur coup quatre vidéos j'en ai fait
il n'ya pas longtemps
et moi j'aime pas trop le biographique
normalement j'aime pas trop d'histoires
biographique parce que
déjà ça limite à une personne n'apprend
pas forcément en compte le contexte
autour de cette personne contexte social
économique de l'époque et aussi la
souvent faute de sources ça se résume à
du l'histoire de la noblesse genre
secrets d'histoire
et
du coup c'est pas trop mon truc c'est
pour ça que je fais assez peu
biographique dans les autres vidéos
jamais jamais mais là pour les femmes je
trouvais que c'était important et donc
je compte bien continuer régulièrement
eh ben on arrive au dernier épisode en
date celui sur les autels princier où
j'ai pu bénéficier d'un nouvel éclairage
parce que je me suis acheté en fin de
l'éclairage et bientôt pour ce qui est
des progrès techniques
j'aurai un nouvel appareil photo je me
suis commandé un réflexe parce
qu'actuellement je forme avec un bridge
donc qui me permet juste d'appuyer sur
filmé mais pas de faire du réglage du
genre mise au point balance des blancs
tout ça il n'a pas donc ça me permettra
de faire des choses plus belle j'espère
et du coup bilan est entièrement positif
parce que cette chaîne déjà ça m'a
permis beaucoup de m'épanouir
j'adore faire ça j'adore passer du temps
déjà à lire et afficher des livres dont
je prends des notes tout en les lisant
ce qui est un truc que je trouvais
chiant quand j'étais à la fac mais là
j'aime beaucoup
et forcément j'aborde des sujets que je
peux pas abordé en classe parce que
c'est pas un programme ou alors que je
ne peux aborder que que rapidement donc
c'est pas ces stimulants et donc cette
chaîne ça me permet de
voilà de faire des choses que je ne peux
pas faire autrement de travailler sur
des sujets pour lesquels j'aurai pas
l'occasion travailler sinon et donc
j'adore puis ça m'a permis de développer
de nouvelles compétences aussi du genre
à utiliser une caméra et qui disait des
logiciels de montage et tout ça ça peut
être utile dans la vie et donc pour moi
face à refaire cette chaîne c'est devenu
une passion j'ai l'intention de
continuer le plus longtemps possible
en plus ça m'a aussi permis de
rencontrer des gens de participer à des
conférences parfois comme j'avais
participé à sos neurones à nantes aux
historiques de montbazon l'année
dernière et puis je fais plein de
rencontres d'autres vidéaste se fait des
apéros tous ensemble c'est trop bien
coucou vidéo vidéo qui m'a permis de
faire un live aussi avec hugo de
confession d'histoire et c'était très
sympa et j'ai des projets toujours avec
chroniques de prendre bien sûr
j'aimerais bien commencer à sortir un
petit peu du cadre
la bibliothèque d'ailleurs jusqu'à 100
d'aliénor aujourd'hui mais j'aimerais
bien pouvoir tourner à l'extérieur
peut-être dans des musées des
institutions donc je vais m'efforcer de
faire ça peut-être d'ici l'année
prochaine on verra ça serait bien j'ai
aussi écrit une web série
alors j'en parle mais je pense que je la
ferai un jour parce que ça m'a beaucoup
plu de l'écrire mais déjà ces techniques
parce que ça demande des compétences que
j'ai pas forcément niveau montage effets
spéciaux c'est toujours en lien avec
chroniques de profs mais sa part plus ça
ne pas du tout mob séries historiques
s'est plutôt humoristique et donc ces
techniques et il me faudrait une équipe
surtout que moi j'habite à lille que la
plupart des vidéastes que je connais ne
sont pas ravis
donc j'aimerais la faire un jour elle
sortira peut-être mais je garantis pas
que ça soit cette année on verra mais en
tout cas je les écris ça m'a fait
plaisir
non mais enfin je voudrais remercier
toutes les personnes qui regardent les
vidéos déjà qu'ils commencent les
partages et les personnes aussi qui
finance en partie une vidéo je reviens
pas sur mes moyens de financement plus
tard mais j'aimerais vraiment continuer
et si un jour je pouvais atteindre un
niveau qui me permettrait de prendre un
temps partiel par exemple je le ferai
parce que ça permettrait de faire plus
de vidéos et c'est vraiment ça qui me
plaît et donc maintenant j'ai trois
moyens de financement sur la chaîne
ils y allaient view youtube puisque je
monétise précieux notables locaux tout
en montée à bloc mais donc je touche un
peu d'argent grâce au vu j'ai créé aussi
un tipi dont je mets le lien à chaque
fois à la fin des vidéos et d'ailleurs
je remercie toutes les personnes vous
êtes 35 qui me semble à contribuer à mon
tipi et ça me fait très plaisir
et depuis peu j'ai aussi créé un outil
qui est un autre moyen de financement
j'en avais déjà parlé dans une autre
vidéo met donc en gros au lieu de donner
de l'argent si vous aimez ce que je fais
vous pouvez regarder une pub et ça me
rapporte de l'argent et je le rappelle
rarement dans ma vidéo donc là je vais
vous redire ici
si vous aimez partager abonnez vous déjà
ça vous n'êtes pas mal à être abonné
mais partager ce que je fais n'hésitez
pas à mettre sur twitter facebook à
mettre des pousses bleus et des
commentaires même juste pour le
référencement
parce que je te mettre un commentaire
pour le référencement ça permet d'être
plus mise en avant sur l'algorithme de
youtube auxquelles je ne comprends pas
grand chose ça m'aide et est donc c'est
bien et donc je remercie j'ai déjà dit
je crois je mette fin à cette nouvelle
vidéo parce que je commence à plus avoir
grand chose à dire je porte un chapeau
vous avez remarqué c'est pas pour faire
style enfin un petit peu il s'appelle
winston et je porte surtout parce que
j'avais cheveux gras jeu pas vraiment
n'importe quoi là je vais arrêter sinon
je m a rejoint de la flûte et ça n'a
peut-être pas vous plaire bonjour merci
a bientot l'épisode de mars est écrit et
se retourne et sûrement la semaine
prochaine donc il sortira début mars
comme d'habitude et je vous aime et vous
fait des bisous et merci pour ces trois
ans et pour toutes les années à venir
au revoir
[Musique]
m